es ist wieder soweit wir starten in eine
neue ausfahrt runde also schnappt euch
eure saatgut tütchen und macht eure
aussagen mit mir man kann in my super
viel immer noch aussehen und es stehen
hier auf die eisheiligen mitte mai und
danach können wir die tomaten auberginen
und die paprika die ganzen gemüse
richtig spaß machen nach draußen
pflanzen
darum wird es heute also auch gehen wir
starten jetzt mit der anzucht und ich
zeige euch welche gemüse ihr jetzt in
die erde bringen können und wir fangen
an mit dem ganzen wintergemüse denn
jetzt ist die zeit wo man an den winter
denken muss wenn ihr im winter immer
noch ganz viel auf und die ganzen
anderen wintergemüse essen möchte und
aus ihrem garten ernten möchtet dann
bringt die jetzt in die erde weil die
brauchen diesen vorsprung die müssen im
winter schon groß sein deswegen muss man
die rechtzeitig im jahr aussehen und da
fangen wir jetzt an mit dem winter auch
die sorte die wir anbauen heißt
blaugrüner winter den bauen wir seit
jahren an und sind super zufrieden geben
und da sehe ich jetzt einfach ein paar
samen in ein schälchen bedecke sie mit
erde können alle in einem töpfchen
bleiben bis man sie dann am ende nach
draußen pflanzten vereins sieht man
einfach die pflänzchen die alle zusammen
in einem topf gewachsen sind und im
pflanzt die einzelnen ins beet so leicht
andrücken und natürlich beschriften
nicht vergessen dass hier sind übrigens
eisstückchen da mir auch viele gefragt
was wieder zum beschriften nehmen finde
ich ganz toll wenn man da kein plastik
müll hat und am besten immer mit einem
bleistift beschriften ich habe das viel
zu oft schon mit allerdings gemacht und
das lässt sich einfach raus und man kann
am ende nichts mehr lesen was auf dem
schildchen draufsteht wir machen mit
einem richtig tollen anderen
wintergemüse weiter das ist der zirkus
den canon in deutschland zu wenig leute
ich hab das saatgut hier auch glaube ich
aus polen importiert oder etwas polnisch
ich kann den namen auf jeden fall nicht
aussprechen von diesen sorten mixed das
ist auch das einzige saatgut dass ich
verwende das nicht ideologisch ist und
vielleicht sogar hybrid ich kann es
leider nicht erkennen auf der packung
aber ziel cool ist so ein toller frost
alter kohl den baut man eigentlich zur
zierde an also weil er halt so
wunderschön ist aber man kann den auch
essen ich finde es immer schön wenn
gemüse nicht nur lecker sind sondern
auch im beet und auf dem teller richtig
schön
sehen die sehe ich jetzt auch alle
erstmal in ein töpfchen und dann krieg
ich die sobald die aus dem kein blatt
stadium raus sind und ihre ersten
richtigen laubblätter gebildet haben
sodass jeder dann später ein eigenes
töpfchen bekommt tipps machen wir weiter
mit dem weißkohl auch wenn das kein
klassisches wintergemüse ist obwohl er
sehr frost hat ist also man kann ihn
ruhig auch länger noch im beet stehen
lassen der steckt voraus ziemlich gut
weg wie vor viele andere gemüse auch den
man das oft gar nicht zutraut ich sehe
jetzt eine sorte aus die heißt
holsteiner platter ihr könnt aber auch
wenn ihr sauerkraut herstellen wollte
thomaner aussehen und dann euer eigenes
sauerkraut herstellen das geht natürlich
auch mit vielen anderen sorten ich kann
mir vorstellen dass diese sorte dafür
auch super gut geeignet ist aber manche
sorten eignen sich dafür einfach ein
bisschen besser weil die zum beispiel in
knackigere sauerkraut abgeben und
deswegen stehen wir total auf diese
sorte domäne
als nächstes steht der rosenkohl auf dem
programm für den es jetzt auch zeit der
braucht auch ein bisschen vorsprung
ich finde sogar dass es im mai auf so
ein bisschen später zum rosenkohl so
sehen es kommt natürlich immer auf die
sorte an manche kann man auch noch im
juni und juli wunderbar auswählen aber
ich mache das meistens lieber ein
bisschen früher so dass sie die zeit
haben dann auch richtig schön groß zu
werden und am ende auch guten ertrag
abzuwerten ein anderer winter cooling
jetzt aussehen ist der grünkohl und der
palm kohl die sind sicher super ähnlich
wie es nicht so gerne grünkohl deswegen
haben wir den letztes jahr zum beispiel
überhaupt nicht angebaut aber ja so ab
und zu ist das schon nicht schlecht ihr
werdet wahrscheinlich auf die barrikaden
gehen bei ihren kunden bestimmt total
lecker findet aber ich freue mich auf
jeden fall auf dem palmbühl weil er so
wunderschön ist da bauen wir die sorte
nero die toskana an kann man aber auch
echt noch deutlich später im jahr
aussehen also das ist jetzt nicht
wirklich nicht eilig das jetzt
überstehen
und dann sehe ich jetzt noch die sorte
ostfriesische palme aus sie kennen
bestimmt auch viele von euch schlägt
sich gut im garten siebten guten ertrag
auch sie typisch aus was will man mehr
grünkohl ist übrigens super
unempfindlich was diese ganzen chor
schädlinge angeht weißkohl rotkohl
blumenkohl usw
die werden ja super schnell von allen
möglichen schädlingen befallen und der
grünkohl auch also gerade auch die weiße
fliege aber ich bin mit dem cool
weißling hat man da viel weniger
probleme also vielleicht als kleine idee
für diejenigen von euch die sonst immer
so unter den kollegen leiden
wir machen weiter mit dem salat da sehe
ich jetzt die sorte pirat auf weil die
so schön verschoss fest ist salat mich
dir im sommer immer ganz gerne blühen
und schmeckt dann nicht mehr so locker
und deswegen ist es ganz gut wenn man
sich im jahresverlauf immer ein paar
unterschiedliche sorten zurecht legt er
macht sich super gut im sommer und im
winter haben wir dann andere sorten die
da super gut funktionieren und sehr
forsthart sind wichtig beim salat ne das
licht keiner also diese haben nur
obenauf streu sind so dass sie nicht von
erde bedeckt sind oder höchstens ganz
dünn mit erde bedeckt sind
da keimt auch super toll das ist echt
sehr sehr einfach denn hier vorzuziehen
und der salat wird auch später in
einzelnen pikiert wenn er größer ist ich
sehe jetzt auch noch die sorte little
gem aus dies nicht ganz so schoss fest
aber ich mag die einfach total gerne
deswegen kommt jetzt auch noch mal ins
gewaltsam mit einem wintergemüse dem
wirsing und da kann ich mich diesmal
echt nicht entscheiden
tatsächlich habe ich eine salz zu
typischen doppelt da sehen wir
normalerweise immer die sorte winter
fürst aus der kammer aber dieses jahr
das habe ich am letzten videos angezeigt
im letzten april xanten video bis wir
mal etwas neues ausprobieren das ist
eine kreuzung aus wirsing und weißkohl
ich weiß nicht warum sie violet ist
violett rotes um blatt stimme das super
schön vor und deswegen bandagiert auch
noch mal in die erde
wenn ihr euch wundert warum wir jeden
monat immer wieder die gleichen gemüse
aussehen das machen wir um eine
gestaffelte ernte zu haben dass die in
unterschiedlichen stadien reif werden
ich mache das seit dem ich diese
monats aus video mache für euch ein
bisschen extremer werde ich euch ja auch
hier irgendwas zeigen möchte
normalerweise würde ich nicht jeden
monat will sing aussehen wenn es
irgendwie möglich ist in der tendenz ist
das schon super wichtig damit man nicht
nur einmal die kurze ehrentag sondern
das ganze jahr über immer wieder ehren
und kann deswegen versuchen wir es
ebenso zu staffeln das ist ein bisschen
mehr so ist als wenn wir in den laden
gehen und uns unser gemüse da kaufen da
würden wir uns ja auch immer hiervon ein
bisschen hier ein bisschen nehmen und
nicht einfach einen ganzen einkaufswagen
voll wirsing auf einem auf das
überfordert ein schnell und es ist dann
schade wenn es einem die lust am
gärtnern verdirbt der winter wird landet
aber jetzt auch noch ein ausstechen
dann habe ich mir noch den rot kollegen
den lasse ich jetzt weg weil wir haben
echt genug rotkohl vorgezogen dieses
frühe aber für diejenigen von euch die
den vielleicht noch nicht zu viel in
ihre mannschaft stehen haben den könnt
ihr jetzt auf jeden fall auch aussehen
man kann jetzt auch noch gurken zucchini
kürbis und millionen im haus vorziehen
wir haben das im april fung gemacht
deswegen packe ich euch das video wo ich
euch zeigen wie das geht nach unten in
die video beschreibung dann könnt ihr
euch das später noch anschauen wir
werden dieses mal eine kleine
spezialbehandlung vornehmen für unsere
pflänzchen weil wir dieses jahr ein
super großes problem mit trauermücken
haben und viele von euch wahrscheinlich
auch die kommen immer mal wieder also
viele leute haben mit denen zu kämpfen
wir bekämpfen die in den bewerb tafeln
aufstellen und mit nematoden arbeiten
weil wir trauern mit mir ist das so dass
die larven eben an den pflanzenwurzeln
herumknabbern und dadurch wird sterben
die pflanzen ab die sehen aus als hätten
sie seit wochen candies wasser mehr
bekommen und sterben einfach ab obwohl
du immer weiter geht das total
frustrierend
deswegen geben wir in der methoden mit
ins kies wasser die diese larven
paralysieren parasitären und den daneben
den garaus machen und deswegen feuchte
ich die erde jetzt erst mal mit meiner
tollen ball brause und dann mische ich
jetzt nematoden ins gießwasser das soll
man immer aus bringen wenn die erde
schon feucht ist
andrea sehr gut um und dann ließ sich
damit jetzt nochmal über die pflänzchen
drüber so dass sich hoffentlich keine
trauermücken in unseren teppichen
ausbreiten weil das ist super ärgerlich
um so viele junge pflänzchen an die
verliert eine andere maßnahme die auch
gut gegen trauermücken hilft wäre eine
dünne sandschicht auf der erde aus zu
bringen da würde ich aber erst warten
bis die pflänzchen dann alle auch aus
der erde schauen bevor wir das dann
machen falls es nicht so besser wird
aber bisher das ganz gut geholfen nur
die nematoden zu verwenden und die gelb
bafin zusammen um die herumschwirrenden
fliegen abzufangen
damit die keine eier mehr legen können
und jetzt schauen wir mal welche gemüse
wie jetzt im mai nach draußen direkt ins
beet sehen können da fange ich erst mal
mit denen an die auch anfang mai schon
gehen die also ein bisschen frost härter
sind und wo man nicht bis auf die
eisheiligen warten muss und dann später
erzähle ich euch welche gemüse ihr nach
den eisheiligen noch aussehen könnte das
ist einmal der chicorée den kann man
jetzt wunderbar ins freiland säen
ich habe euch ja ein theorie video
versprochen und ich hoffe richtig dass
ich das dieses jahr filmen kann letztes
jahr hat der theorie die ganzen frauen
und hühner attacken leider nicht
überlebt unsere nachbarn haben hühner
und frauen und die kommen jeden tag in
den garten und reißen alles raus was
ihnen unter die füße kommt fährt den
figuren dieses jahr so gut beschützen
wie ich kann und dann hoffentlich im
winter ein einlagerung video für euch
filmen so dass ihr wisst was ihr mit
euren figur zu ihnen anstellt damit ihr
die im winter im haus treiben können
ärzten kann man jetzt auch nach draußen
sehen sowohl die zuckererbsen als auch
die mark erbsen das ist auch ganz clever
auch wenn ihr vielleicht im februar oder
mehr als schon ärzten gesellt hat das
jetzt noch mal zu machen dazu wachsen
relativ schnell da könnt ihr immer mal
wieder neue von aussehen so dass ihr da
immer mit frischen erbsen versorgt seit
das sind auch eines der besten gemüse
oder wenn man diese vom strauch zupft
sind so lecker und süßem an die frisch
ist und sobald man die bisschen länger
lagert oder man die im laden kauft haben
die ihrem ganzen zucker schönen stärke
umgewandelt das heißt das ist ein
genießer wo es sich mal so richtig lohnt
das selber im garten anzubauen weil die
frisch einfach um längen besser
schmecken als alles was man im land
kaufen kann man geld kann jetzt auch
wieder nachgesät werden beim mangold
muss man nicht so viele staffeln weil
man den ja immer wieder beenden kann man
kann entweder nur die äußeren blätter
ernten und den rest stehen lassen sodass
er nachwachsen kann oder man schneidet
den ungefähr so viel über dem boden ab
so dass der wieder austreibt ist nicht
verkehrt jetzt noch meine spätere
mangold auszumachen so dass ihr wenn die
älteren mangold pflanzen irgendwann
nicht mehr so viel power haben wieder
frischen nachschub abtrocknen kann man
nicht mehrmals ernten deswegen sehen wir
die quasi jeden monat aus jetzt gehen
wir auch zu dem lager karotten über ich
habe jetzt am wochenende zum beispiel
gerade ganz ganz ganz viele karotten
ausgesät also sagen wir mal so 30 reihen
meter sind es bestimmt gewesen
einfach damit wir dann eine große ernte
haben die wir dann im herbst einlagern
können in unserer ehrt miete und den
ganzen winter über frische karotten aus
der miete eben ernten können aber zum
scheren sehe ich natürlich kleinere
sätze aus und das ist auch wieder total
sinnvoll auch wenn ihr nichts einlagern
volt da jetzt noch mal eine kleine menge
karotten samen in die erde zu bringen so
dass euch der nachschub nicht ausgeht
genau so seht ihr jetzt auch am besten
noch eure pastinaken aus wenn ihr das
nicht gemacht habt das wird langsam
schon ein bisschen spät für die
pastinaken sind ja ein wintergemüse die
sind ein bisschen langsamer als die
karotten das heißt sie brauchen ein
bisschen mehr vorlaufzeit die kann man
auch im februar eigentlich schon in die
erde bringen die radieschen kann man ja
eigentlich eh rund ums jahr sehen die
gehen jetzt natürlich auch wieder
genauso wie der rettich der auch auf
meiner liste steht und rucola kann man
jetzt auch sehen rucola ist echt so ein
cooles gemüse das wächst so schnell und
wenn ihr das gerne mögen vielleicht so
eine pizza mit frischem rucola drauf das
ist einfach super lecker und dann so
gehobeltem parmesan
ich bin ganz froh dass und der ricola
trieben schon wieder richtig groß ist
ich freue mich schon man kann jetzt auch
noch zwiebeln sehen die könnt ihr
einfach direkt ins beet sehen
achtet immer darauf dass das beet
möglichst unkrautfrei ist weil sich die
zwiebel nicht so gut gegen andere
pflanzen behaupten können zwiebeln und
möhren sind zum beispiel auch eine tolle
mischkultur da könnt ihr beide auf ein
beet packen weil die möhren unkraut auch
nicht so toll finden die passen sehr gut
zusammen auch aus vielen anderen gründen
ist das eine tolle mischkultur könnte
jetzt auch speck zwiebeln pflanzen da
ist die ernte einem ein bisschen
sicherer es ist ein bisschen leicht
in ost ex liebe in anzubauen ist
natürlich ein bisschen teurer wenn man
sie kaufen muss aber für anfänger auf
jeden fall die leichtere wahl wenn man
seine eigenen zwiebeln anbauen möchte
und wenn mitte mai die eisheiligen
vorbei sind das heißt wenn keine
spätfröste mehr anstehen das ist in
diesem jahr ab dem 16
mai der fall aber wenn du das in einem
anderen jahr 2021 schaust dann schau
lieber nochmal den kalender dann können
eben auch die mimosen die empfindlichen
die frostbeulen unter den gemüsen
ausgesät werden
das sind zb einmal die bush und die
stangenbohnen die sollte man erst sehen
wenn wirklich keine früchte mehr
anstehen sonst sind die ganz schnell
hinüber machen wir weiter mit den
gemüsen die man jetzt raus pflanzen kann
also die pflänzchen die entweder in der
gärtnerei oder auf dem wochenmarkt
gekauft habt oder die ihr selber im haus
vorgezogen habt das geht jetzt mit allen
kohlgemüse die sind ja sowieso schon
seit ungefähr märz mit dabei die sind
relativ frost hat das heißt sie kann man
sobald sie abgeschaltet sind direkt nach
draußen ins beet pflanzen brokkoli
weißkohl rotkohl und so weiter geht wie
alle kohlgemüse sind jetzt möglich und
auch schon lange mich genauso wie der
salat und die zwiebeln und den lauch die
ihr vorgezogen hat das da sind meine
pflanzkartoffeln damals nämlich der
perfekte monat um kartoffeln zu pflanzen
und wie das funktioniert und zwar ganz
ohne umgraben und wie man mit denen ein
ganz neues beet anlegen kann
darum geht es nächste woche also
schaltet auf jeden fall nächsten samstag
wieder ein dann kommen wir zu den
wärmeliebenden kandidaten die ihre aus
pflanzen können wenn die eisheiligen
vorbei sind und das sind die gewesen die
so richtig spaß machen
ihr könnt dann tomatenpflanzen gurken
zucchini auberginen paprika die ganzen
also auch melonen können dann im spiel
die kürbisse sind sehr frostempfindlich
das heißt sie dürfen auch nach den
eisheiligen nach draußen zum thema
tomatenpflanzen was er jetzt für uns
alle ansteht gibt es super viel zu sagen
und super viel was man falsch bzw
richtig machen kann damit man dann am
ende auch nur super ernte hat und
darüber hatte ich auch schon mal ein
komplett eigenes video macht also schaut
euch das gerne anders verlinkt ich euch
da trieben ansonsten geht raus macht die
welt ein bisschen grüner wir sehen uns
am samstag jeder und zehn für ein neues
video